so the bite administration has somehow
nearly 1 billion records of lawful
firearms purchases made by americans
this is according to a new report by the
washington free beacon now to be clear a
federal firearms registry is explicitly
banned by law the congress is banned
they're not allowed
to
to keep any kind of registry like that
now they can check your credentials when
they when you buy a gun
hunter biden lied on his form that's a
felony they've done nothing about it but
they can't maintain a registry
last year joe biden explained his goal
watch
and so what happens is i've gotten atf
alcohol tobacco and firearms
i have them increase their budget and
increase their capacity along with the
justice department
to go after the gun shops that are not
abiding by the law of doing background
checks but my point is all across the
country
and it's not because the gun shops in
the cities are selling these guns
they are either
shadow gun dealers and or gun shops that
are not abiding by the law
so we're going to do major
investigations and shut those guys down
and put some of them in jail for what
they're doing selling these weapons
yeah again his son broke federal
firearms law and they did nothing about
it they're letting people run around our
cities with guns and not arresting them
they're trying to disarm people who
didn't vote for them i mean it just
couldn't be clear at this point jd vance
is a best-selling author he's now
running for senate in the state of ohio
and we're happy to have him join us
tonight jd vance thanks so much for
coming on so we've got record crime in
our biggest cities and that's joe
biden's response
yeah that's exactly right tucker so you
think about it this database is
ultimately a back door to a gun registry
in this country and if you look at what
liberals have done in europe but what
they've done in australia once you allow
gun registry you effectively allow the
disarming of your citizenry this is
ultimately about destroying the second
amendment just as the democrats alliance
with big tech is about destroying the
first amendment and my basic argument
here tucker is look if the democrats are
going to ignore the heavily armed drug
cartels on our southern border but use
the atf to go after law-abiding citizens
why don't we just get rid of the atf
well that is such a great point i mean
there's a narco state
right across the border from texas
arizona new mexico and california i mean
the biggest narco state in the
hemisphere heavily armed no one's doing
anything about it at all but they're mad
because you've got a 12-gauge in your
closet i mean why do we have an atf
well it's a great question and you know
i'm running
in the senate against this fraud of a
democrat tim ryan and you look at this
guy he portrays himself as a working
class democrat but at the end of the day
he's gone along with the inflation
policies that destroyed the dollar he's
gone along with the ship our jobs to
china policies which have destroyed the
working class wages and now he's going
along with policies that destroy the
second amendment in this country at the
end of the day democrats say they care
about the little people you should care
about their values and you should care
about their rights i'm so sick of the
democrats saying they care when all they
offer is a government check instead of a
government that actually defends
people's basic liberties that's exactly
right you'd think that a democrat from
the mahoning valley of ohio could defend
gun rights but no it's really changed
that party has changed it's sad jd vance
great to see you tonight thank you
thanks doctor hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else